Eric Sicot nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
Eric on revient ce soir sur les
rassemblements front contre front
organisés hier à Germigny dans l'Yonne
hier en raison d'un problème technique
retour donc à Germigny ou le président
udi du département en drevilliers avait
convié tous les candidats de gauche et
de droite opposés au FN l'extrême droite
n'a pas apprécié quelques militants ce
sont donc invités Nathalie bafer
Jean-François Gilmar
candidat de droite
quand même arrivé en tête dans l'Yonne
le président
udi du département renouvelle son appel
au front républicain j'appelle
clairement les électeurs de droite
qu'ils appartiennent à l'UMP au centre
droit à voter pour les candidats de
gauche qui sont face au FN et de la même
manière les candidats de droite qui sont
opposés aux candidat FN reçoivent
l'appui et les encouragements des élus
de gauche et des électeurs de gauche
pour être élus au deuxième tour dimanche
soir André Villiers se démarque ainsi
clairement de la position nationale de
l'UMP en faveur du Nini quelques élus de
l'UMP sont tout de même là est plus
discret
au bureau départemental de l'UMP nous
avons arrêté une ligne qui est tout
simplement d'appeler à voter pour les
candidats les plus enracinés localement
les plus engagés dans leur vie
associative dans la vie communale
intercommunale parce que c'est un mandat
local soudain la Réunion et quelque peu
troublés par l'arrivée de quelques
membres du Front national évidemment pas
convié
avant 1990 cotisations 1500 euros de
retraite par mois c'est pas du vol le
ton monte entre Dominique bourreau
candidat PS à Pont-sur-Yonne qui s'est
retiré pour faire barrage ou FN et le
candidat du parti frontiste justement la
bataille n'était pas perdue mais le
risque était vraiment trop fort devoir
passer le parachuté du Front National et
de le voir sur le nord du département de
l'Yonne alors qu'il ne le connaît pas
d'ailleurs
il m'en veut absolument il comptait
absolument sur le maintien de cette
triangulaire c'est pas un front à
républicain déjà c'est un front anti
républicain anti-national orchestré par
Monsieur Villier donc ses amis
udi umpps donc je dirais que c'est le
front de la caste politique casse tu MPS
contre les patriotes on saura dimanche
soir si cet appel au front républicain a
trouvé un écho auprès des électeurs le
FN est présent dans 19 des bouton où
l'envoie pour le second tour
alors on a compris l'attention reste
forte dans l'Yonne à propos du Front
National et cela se vérifie sur les
réseaux sociaux oui illustration sur
Twitter avec l'un des échanges musclés
entre le candidat battu sans étiquette
Guillaume gextine et le
fnaciano qui avait écrit stop à l'Empire
dans un précédent tweet son adversaire y
voit une allusion je cite au nazis à la
Soral qui a beaucoup écrit sur le
soi-disant empire israélo-américain en
Côte-d'Or vivent tension aussi et encore
à cause du FN ouais le groupe de gauche
s'indigne de latitude de François
Sauvadet adepte d'une IPS ni FN alors
qu'il appelle tous les électeurs de
gauche à faire battre le candidat du
Front national et à vous et à voter pour
lui dans son propre canton pas de
réponse de François somadet mais un
autre de ses communiqués relayé par les
candidats de droite il s'offusent que
dans le canton de Dijon 4 des
agissements du PS qui auraient forcé les
écologistes battu à soutenir les
socialistes propos démentis cet
après-midi par les candidats écologistes
eux-mêmes enfin dans la multitude des
tweets de cette la dernière journée on
notera le tacle du député européen
Arnaud donjon après que le journal
l'opinion a publié une liste de
présidents pas sûr d'être élus dimanche
et parmi eux Rémy Chatron pas sur des
traits élus et critiques en
Saône-et-Loire c'est un euphémisme à
48,5 % pour un MP udi au premier tour
allez on reste ensemble avec un zoom sur
Chalon nous allons ce soir sur le canton
de Châlons effectivement où la gauche
affrontent le Front national la droite
est éliminée mais elle ne s'est pas
exprimée en faveur du Front républicain
du coup le binôme de gauche s'interroge
et c'est un reportage de Stéphane Robert
et Gabriel talon
blanche SIA et Gérard chassant ne ménage
pas leurs efforts ce canton le Front
National veut le gagner dimanche soir
vraiment on travaille parce que j'ai lu
un petit peu dans les discours me fait
rien du tout on en a parcouru des
kilomètres et bien on parle aux gens
avant on a fait des marchés alors les
gens sont sympathiques comme tout
pourtant les critiques se sont
multipliées tout au long de la campagne
sur leur programme trop générale et pas
assez locale ce que démence cette
médecin retraitée arrivait en tête
dimanche dernier avec 13 voies d'avance
sur le duo socialiste
moi j'ai bien recherché
les attributions des conseillers
départementaux c'est donc les maisons de
retraite les crèches les
routes enfin tout ce qui concerne le
l'aide aux personnes toute la semaine le
binôme socialiste à lui multiplié le
porte à porte objectif convaincre les
indécis d'aller voter dimanche pour
faire barrage au FN je n'imagine pas que
le Front national puisse être dimanche
soir à l'issue du scrutin en position de
siéger au conseil départemental et
lorsque nous évoquons et nous partageons
avec les personnes il ne l'évoque pas
eux-mêmes il ne faut pas se tromper là
aussi parce que il ne s'agit pas des
personnes nous n'avons rien contre les
personnes il s'agit des idées du Front
national on a bien compris que la
candidate c'est Marine Le Pen et qui
vise d'autres élections et nous on
attire l'attention des gens c'est la vie
quotidienne le Conseil départemental et
donc il va falloir qu'il vote pour leur
vie quotidienne et non pas pour une
élection potentielle de Marine Le Pen ou
aux élections présidentielles de 2017
quant à la droite Chalonnaise incarnée
notamment par Gilles plâtré elle est
fidèle dans sa globalité au Nini de
Nicolas Sarko zy le maire UMP de
Chalon-sur-Saône a par exemple décidé de
ne pas donner de consigne de vote sur
Chalon 1 inquiétant que la droite
républicaine fasse le choix de laisser
passer le Front national c'est un vrai
choix
en 2011 Françoise verju Peltier avait
déjà bataillé au second tour face au FN
mais elle avait à l'époque 800 voix
d'avance sur ses adversaires
dans la Nièvre il y aura dimanche 12
duels et 5 triangulaires triangulaires
notamment à Corbigny oui trois binômes
ont effectivement réussi à se qualifier
à Corbini le duo de gauche est en
ballotage favorable il a reçu 11 voix de
moins que son adversaire de droite mais
il devrait pouvoir bénéficier des voies
du Front de Gauche éliminer au premier
tour Régis Guillon et Cécile Claveau
avec on se voit des cars sur le PS
dimanche soir le binôme UMP viré en tête
confirmant la dynamique de la droite sur
ce territoire après la victoire contre
la gauche aux municipales la corbine
mais dans cette partie d'un hibernet
Morvan plus qu'un renouvellement des
étiquettes c'est un changement de tête
que semble réclamer les électeurs Fabien
Bazin compte pourtant bien sauver la
sienne au sein du futur conseil
départemental et pense que son bilan et
ses projets pour le canton devrait lier
des dans ce type d'élection ce qui
importe surtout c'est d'être au contact
quotidien des habitants d'être sur des
propositions concrètes autour des sujets
de santé de maison médicale de reprise
de la démographie médicale d'activités
d'emplois évidemment d'activités
agricoles bien sûr avec le marché de
Corbigny et l'abattoir nous sommes pas
dans le calcul nous sommes sur le
terrain au service des habitants c'est
comme ça que les choses doivent
fonctionner tous ceux qui ont marqué
leur opposition et c'est vrai aussi
d'une partie de la gauche qui rejette le
ce qui a été fait au niveau
départemental et qui rejette parfois
aussi l'attitude des conseillers
généraux sortants et bien je dis un très
large rassemblement dont le seul mot
d'ordre est faire battre la majorité
départementale mais avec un véritable
projet que nous avons largement exposé
avant le premier tour dans cette
triangulaire sur le canton de Corbigny
Marcel Stéphan aurait pu donner
l'avantage à la droite mais à condition
que le candidat du Front national existe
et le fronti St a hésité avant vite de
renoncer la fois le deuxième tour c'est
vrai que ça pose une réflexion que je me
suis vraiment posé et
on a comment dirais-je nationalisé
politiser ses élections et pour nous
l'UMP et le PS c'est exactement la même
et puis c'est déferlement de haine de la
part de l'UMP dimanche soir sur tous les
médias m'a fait prendre cette décision
de maintenir et par respect pour mes
électeurs qui m'ont amené au deuxième
tour un Front national en arbitre une
droite montante une gauche en résistance
le deuxième tour à Corbigny s'annonce
serré au premier le PS qui défend le
canton a en tout cas senti le vent du
boulet
merci Eric on se retrouve à dimanche
pour une grande soirée élection sur
France 3 à partir de 19h et jusqu'à 23h
merci à vous